reven family is speaking out this
morning about the death of their little
dog aboard a United Airlines flight they
say that a flight attendant forced them
to put the ten month old French Bulldog
in an overhead bend and they say he was
kept there for the entire three and a
half hour flight from Houston to New
York on Monday the United has apologized
Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan National
Airport outside Washington DC with the
story Kris this is heartbreaking good
morning - good morning heartbreaking
indeed the death of this little puppy is
causing widespread outrage becoming
United latest PR disaster now the
airline is taking full responsibility
and says it's investigating but the
question that people are asking over and
over again it's burning up Twitter this
morning how could this happen it's just
sad the way he has to just leave for
eleven-year-old Sophia ceballos and her
mother catalina rebelled o coquito a
french bulldog puppy was a part of the
family we took him everywhere on the
United Airlines flight from Houston to
New York's LaGuardia Airport Monday
rebelled Oh put her dog in this carrier
but struggled to get it under the seat
in front of her
the family says a flight attendant
insisted the bag and capito inside go in
the overhead bin I was like it's a dog
it's a dog II can't breathe there and
she's like it doesn't matter it she felt
the dog and she put him up there the
family says they heard coquito barking
for two hours then he stopped they
wanted to check on him but say they
couldn't we tried but like there was a
lot of turbulence and we we weren't
allowed to stand up when the flight was
over they found coquito had died a
fellow passenger posted this photo of
the puppy saying my heart broke with
theirs as I realized he was gone my mom
was crying she was screaming looking at
him in a statement United says this was
a tragic accident that should never have
occurred as pets should never be placed
in the overhead bin we express our
deepest condolences
there is no circulation at all in there
retired airline captain Danny Kelly says
the pitch-black / had been is dangerous
for any live animal they're scared the
heart rate goes up and they use more
oxygen
there's not enough oxygen in the first
place that just makes it worse
coke eaters family hopes others learn
from his death he carefully buzzer Naima
we just don't want this to happen to
other people
flight attendant told the airline she
didn't realize there was a dog in the
bag she's been described as distraught
the American Kennel Club says French
bulldogs because they have a short nose
they can have difficulty breathing or
have less efficient breathing also the
animals are easily stressed which can
speed up their need to breathe John all
right Chris thanks so much it's so hard
to understand how something like that
can happen when the family insists we
told you there was a dog like an errand
yeah and to hear that the dog had been
barking for two hours is just Twitter's
right how does this happen also how do
you know not know a dog's the in there
if it's been barking for two hours
exactly exactly right